un peu plus grands ce possible
downsizing la taille xl est disponible
dans les coloris cayenne mousse et
aubergines nous n'avons plus le 38 aux
prunes tu voulais apporter en noir mais
c'est vraiment cru que je les veux
écouter j'en ai aucune idée vous
pourriez faire un choix s'il vous plaît
c'est johnson qui n'a jamais semblé être
le genre de gars qui sera qui soit
et la décision de grâce au downsizing
terminé la pression en particulier pour
le fait qu on vit comme des rois meurs
d'envié ne sautez pas à s'en sortir
tu veux mon avis les jo lang seul tort à
l'usure landes aux 100000 dollars se
convertit 112 millions de dollars s'est
acheté un nouveau bracelet en diamants
carrément gages ok allez on fait un peu
si j'étais vous allez subir le processus
définitif et irréversible connu sur le
nom de danse a évolué
messieurs saturdays c'est pour vous paul
soit pas en colère contre -3 pas en
connaître je peux pas quitter ma famille
j'y passais penser à ce que moi je
voulais pas penser à ce que toi tu veux
[ __ ] c'est très sain d'ivato un peu
plus grand si possible je sais que le
divorce ça peut mettre un coup l estime
de soi c'est normal mais avec le down
sizing des fastes gardois tu reprend
tout à zéro j'ai des allergies non
attends je vais enlever mes chaussures
mais ouvre des yeux
le monde est plein de choses à voir
cette femme est très malade techno coup
de tête
mais voilà les personnes qu'on devrait
aider
[Musique]
l'histoire
des grands événements se prépare
actuellement des événements dans ce
secteur pourquoi j'ai fait tout ça pour
pouvoir me retrouver ici
maintenant j'ai enfin l'occasion de
faire une chose vraiment importante
[Musique]
on croit qu'on est dans le monde normal
et puis un truc se produit alors et on
se rend compte que non
[Musique]